SHE’S HAD A LOT OF JOBS.
STEVE: PRIMARY ANCHOR THERE, I
THINK THERE’S A CRISIS AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER AND THE
ADMINISTRATION WON’T CALL IT
THAT, BUT FOX NEWS HAS AN
EXCLUSIVE PEEK AT SOME OF THE
NUMBERS AND IT-- AT LEAST
150,000 MIGRANTS HAVE BEEN
RELEASED INTO THE COUNTRY SINCE
MARCH AND THE FIRST NUMBER AT
THE TOP, CLOSE TO 32,000 WERE
RELEASED BY PAROLE, THAT’S A NEW
ONE.
AINSLEY: THAT MEANS THEY GET
SOME FORM OF LEGAL STATUS.
STEVE: HERE’S THE THING, AINSLEY
, PAROLE IS GRANTED ON A
CASE-BY-CASE BASIS OR URGENT
HUMANITARIAN PURPOSES.
RODNEY THE FORMER BORDER
PATROL CHIEF SAID WHEN I
WAS IN CHARGE AND THAT I
PROBABLY GAVE OUT FIVE
OR 10, TOTAL PER YEAR.
INSTEAD THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION CLOSE TO
32,000.
THEY FOUND A LOOPHOLE TO
LET A WHOLE BUNCH OF
PEOPLE AND SPEAK WHEN HE
SAID HE THINKS THE
ADMINISTRATION IS
ABUSING THE PAROLE
AUTHORITY.
BRIAN: THEY WERE GIVEN A NOTICE
TO REPORT.
AINSLEY: THAT MEANS THEY JUST
HAVE TO NOTICE THE EYES OFFICE
WHEN THEY GET TO WHERE THEY ARE
GOING, THEIR FINAL DESTINATION.
STEVE: THERE IS NO LEGAL
OBLIGATION AND THEY DON’T
ACTUALLY HAVE TO DO IT.
BRIAN: 39,600 RELEASED SINCE
AUGUST 6, OBVIOUSLY THEY DON’T
HAVE THE NUMBER OF THE GOT A
WAYS THIS IS PRETTY
UNBELIEVABLE.
YOU HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATION, THE MEN
AND WOMEN OF BORDER
PATROL AND TEXAS
NATIONAL GUARD HAVE TO
DO THE SAME JOB AND THEY
KNOW WHAT WORKS AND WHAT
DOESN’T AND THE REASON
WE GET THE NUMBERS IS
BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE
DON’T RUN FOR OFFICE.
THEY ARE JUST TRYING TO
CONTROL THE COUNTRY’S
BORDERS AS AN ADMIRABLE
PATRIOTIC THING TO DO IN
THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS
NO INTEREST IN DOING IT.
IN FACT, NOW, WE HAVE A
NEW THING HAPPENING.
WE HAVE MIDDLE-CLASS
PEOPLE FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES DECIDING ON
NOT EVEN GOING TO APPLY
TO GET A VISA I’M GOING
TO WALK THROUGH THE
BORDER AND ACCORDING TO
LINDSEY GRAHAM END UP IN
CONNECTICUT WITH MY
GUCCI BAG AND TRY TO
LIVE A MIDDLE-CLASS LIFE
IN ANOTHER COUNTRY
BECAUSE WE HAVE NO
PROCESS.
STEVE: THERE’S AN ARTICLE THIS
MORNING AND THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL", CO- OWNED WITH OUR
COMPANY, THERE’S 26 MILLION
PEOPLE THAT LOST THEIR JOBS IN
SOUTH AMERICA AND THE CARIBBEAN
ISLANDS AND THAT’S WHY WE SEE 70
PEOPLE, 26 MILLION IN THE LAST
YEAR.
WHAT A LOT OF
MIDDLE-CLASS PEOPLE IN
SOUTH AMERICA ARE DOING
IS TAKING A FLIGHT TO
MEXICO AS CLOSE TO THE
U.S. BORDER AS THEY CAN
AND THEN THEY ARE EITHER
GETTING INTO A TAXI OR A
BUS AND THEY ARE GOING
RIGHT UP TO THE BORDER
AND THEY DROPPED THEM
OFF RIGHT THERE AND THEY
WALK ACROSS AND THEN
THEY JUST START LOOKING.
HEY, WHO CAN I SURRENDER
TO?
BRIAN: WHY WOULD I GO TO ELLIS
ISLAND?
AINSLEY: THE CHIEF U.S. BORDER
PATROL AGENT IN YUMA ARIZONA
SAID THIS, THEY GOT OFF THE
PLANE AND WENT TO A CAB OR TO A
BUS AND LITERALLY WERE DRIVEN UP
AND JUST WALKED UP AND TURNED
THEMSELVES OVER TO US.
STEVE: IF THEY CAN DO IT,
COULDN’T PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING
TO COME INTO OUR COUNTRY FOR
INSTANCE FORBADE PURPOSES LIKE
TERRORISTS DO EXACTLY THE SAME
THING?
THE ANSWER IS YES.
AINSLEY: ESPECIALLY AFTER THE
TALIBAN TAKE OVER IN
AFGHANISTAN.
BRIAN: WHY WOULD ANYONE DO WITH
THE RIGHT WAY AND NOW NO ONE IS
DOING IT THE RIGHT WAY.
LAWRENCE JONES IS ON THE
GROUND WITH MORE THAN 30
MIGRANTS WHEN THEY WERE
CAUGHT ON A RANCHERS
PRIVATE PROPERTY.
AINSLEY: LAWRENCE IS LIVE IN
TEXAS AND HE JOINS US NOW.
HEY, LAWRENCE.
REPORTER: GOOD MORNING, FAMILY.
INTERESTING DAY
YESTERDAY AS I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEND THE
DAY WITH THE TEXAS
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
SAFETY SPECIAL
OPERATIONS AT DIVISION.
WHAT WE SAW WAS
INCREDIBLE.
TAKE A LOOK.
♪
>> ABOUT 30 ILLEGAL
MIGRANTS ON YOUR
PROPERTY.
IS THIS THE FIRST TIME?
>> NO, SIR.
THIS HAPPENS DAILY,
WEEKLY.
THEY SLOW DOWN FOR A
LITTLE BIT, MAYBE TWO OR
THREE WEEKS AGO, BUT
IT’S BACK AGAIN.
WHEN TRUMP WAS IN, IT
WAS LOW AND I NEVER SAW
BORDER PATROL MAYBE ONCE
A WEEK.
NOW THEY ARE HERE TO
HELP, BUT WE CAN ALLOW
THEM.
REPORTER: THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED
TO HELP.
HOW DO YOU FEEL?
>> I’M UPSET.
THAT’S LIKE A PUNCH IN
THE BELL.
>> WE CAN GET THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION
TO ALLOW US TO.
REPORTER: WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE
WHEN THEY ARREST THEM AND THEY
CHARGE THEM WITH CRIMINAL
TRESPASSING.
>> THEY GO TO JAIL AND
WE SLOW IT DOWN A LITTLE
BIT.
REPORTER: WHEN BORDER PATROL
ARREST THEM THEY RELEASE THEM
BACK INTO MEXICO AND HOW LONG
WILL IT TAKE THEM TO BE BACK
OVER HERE?
>> I WOULDN’T BE
SURPRISED IF IT’S
TOMORROW NIGHT.
WHEN YOU HAVE A
REVOLVING DOOR IT WILL
NEVER STOP.
AT THE QUESTION IS WILL
THEY BREAK INTO MY HOUSE
OR WHAT WILL THEY DO?
REPORTER: THAT RUNS THROUGH YOUR
MIND?
>> ALL THE TIME WHEN YOU
ARE ON THE RANCH.
REPORTER: YOU WORRY ABOUT YOUR
FAMILIES A SAFETY?
>> I ALWAYS WORRY ABOUT
MY FAMILY’S SAFETY.
HOW MANY MORE OF THE GOD
WAYS ARE THEY TALKING
ABOUT?
REPORTER: THEM RUNNERS.
IS THAT THEM RIGHT THERE
TAKE THE BOY OUT OF
TEXAS.
♪
WHERE DID YOU COME FROM,
SIR?
MEXICO CITY.
WHAT MADE YOU MAKE TAKE
THIS JOURNEY, SIR.
>> 28 YEARS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THE GOVERNMENT-- DONALD
TRUMP AND THE NEW
PRESIDENT CHANGE THE
RULES AND HE CANCEL MY
CASE.
THAT’S WHY I HAVE TO TRY
TO GO SEE MY FAMILY, YOU
KNOW.
REPORTER: WHAT IS YOUR FRIENDS A
STORY?
>> MY FRIENDS A STORY,
THIS IS MY FRIEND.
THIS IS MY WIFE BROTHER.
>> HAVE YOU BEEN IN
PRISON?
HAVE YOU EVER BEEN
ARRESTED?
>> NO.
>> SAYS HE WAS DEPORTED
FOR NO DRIVER’S LICENSE.
REPORTER: LET’S RUN SUIT--
THROUGH SOME OF THE CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND.
>> THIS INDIVIDUAL OVER
HERE HAS BEEN ARRESTED
FOR POSSESSION OF
METHAMPHETAMINE AND
ILLEGAL ENTRY.
ILLEGAL ENTRY IS A
CHARGE FOR THIS
INDIVIDUAL HERE WAS
ARRESTED FOR MULTIPLE
ILLEGAL ENTRIES, WHICH
ARE DEPORTATION CHARGES.
REPORTER: ARE YOU TRYING TO SEE
THAT SAME WIFE WHEN YOU GET
HERE?
WERE YOU PLANNING TO
MEET HERE-- OR OR IS
THIS ANOTHER WIFE?
THIS IS ANOTHER WIFE.
>> MY GIRLFRIEND.
REPORTER: THEY ARE GETTING READY
TO HEAD TO THE DETENTION CENTER
AND THIS IS PART OF OPERATION
LONE STAR FOR THE PROPERTY
OWNERS GAVE TROOPERS DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC SAFETY THAT PERMISSION
TO COME ON THEIR PROPERTY THEY
COORDINATED WITH THEM AND ONCE
THEY FIGURE THAT OUT SOME
TROOPERS CAME ONTO THE SCENE.
MANY WOMEN PROTECTING
THE BORDER DAY AND NIGHT
AND EVEN FLYING OVER
WITH HELICOPTERS TO BE
EYES IN THE SKY FOR
THOSE ON THE GROUND OF.
>> WE HAVE A GROUP OF
ABOUT A DOZEN.
I DON’T SEE ANY KIDS
WITH THEM, BUT THEY ARE
YOUNG.
HE’S MAYBE IN HIS 30s
AND HE’S IN HIS 20s.
THEY ARE ON THE MOVE
HERE KEEP GOING NORTH.
KEEP GOING.
THERE’S ABOUT 10.
THEY ARE HEADING CLOSER.
WE HAD THE LIGHT ON
THEM.
2:00 O’CLOCK, RIGHT IN
FRONT OF YOU.
>> THEY ARE SURE PICTURE
OF THE GROUP.
>> THERE WE GO.
REPORTER: HEY, GUYS, I JUST GOT
SOME REACTION FROM THE TEXAS
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SAFETY AND
THEY HAVE ARRESTED ABOUT 1200
MIGRANTS ILLEGALLY ENTERING THE
COUNTRY SINCE JULY.
I HOPE YOU GUYS CAUGHT
THAT ONE CLIP OF THE GUY
SAYING HE HAD NO
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND AND
HE WAS ONLY DEPORTED
UNDER DONALD TRUMP
BECAUSE OF HIS DRIVER’S
LICENSE.
WE LATER FOUND OUT AFTER
HE GAVE US THE SOB STORY
HE DID HAVE A RECORD FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE TO I
WILL SEND IT BACK TO YOU
GUYS IN NEW YORK.
AINSLEY: THE ONE ECHO WAS GOING
TO LOOK FOR HIS WIFE?
REPORTER: EXACTLY RIGHT.
HE HAD A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CHARGE AND
THAT’S WHY I ASKED IF HE
WAS GOING BACK TO THAT
SAME WIFE AND HE SAID
NO, I HAVE A NEW WIFE.
STEVE: A LOT GOING ON DOWN
THERE.
BRIAN: PRETTY AMAZING, LAWRENCE
OFF THE TOP OF YOUR HEAD, SHOULD
THE TEXAS GUARD BE DOING THIS,
TROOPERS OR IS THIS SOMETHING
THE BORDER PATROL WOULD NORMALLY
BE DOING?
REPORTER: THEY SHOULDN’T BE
DOING THIS, BUT THEY HAVE NO
CHOICE BUT TO DO THIS BECAUSE A
LOT OF THE TEXAS RESIDENTS ARE
PUTTING PRESSURE ON THE
GOVERNOR, ON THEIR ELECTED
LEADERS TO DO SOMETHING AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS SIMPLY NOT
DOING IT.
THE BORDER PATROL WANT
TO DO THEIR JOB, BUT
THEY AREN’T ALLOWED TO
LOSE-- TO DO BOOK
PATROLS, SO TEXANS HAD
THEIR BACK AGAINST THE
WALL AND LIKE I CONTINUE
TO SAY AND I HAVE FOR
THE LAST THREE WEEKS,
THE LAST DEFENSE, THE
COUNTRY COME THE LAST
DEFENSE FOR TEXAS IS THE
TEXAS DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC SAFETY.
WE SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
PAY FOR THIS IN THE
STATE OF TEXAS.
AINSLEY: YOU SAID THEY WERE
GOING TO A DETENTION CENTER.
WHAT HAPPENS AFTER THAT?
REPORTER: THEY WILL BE CHARGED
WITH CRIMINAL TRESPASS HERE IN
THE STATE OF TEXAS AND THEN THEY
GO THROUGH THE LEGAL CHANNELS
AND THE DA WILL BRING CHARGES
AND THEY WILL GO THROUGH THE
UNITED STATES PROCESS FOR THAT.
AINSLEY: SO WE HAD TO BE
DETERMINED WHETHER OR NOT THEY
ARE SENT BACK HOME TO MEXICO OR
IF THEY CAN STAY?
REPORTER: THEY WILL BE TURNED
OVER TO BORDER PATROL AFTER THEY
DO THAT PERIOD OF TIME, WHATEVER
THE PROCESS IS FOR THE U.S. AND
THEN BORDER PATROL PICKS THEM
UP.
BRIAN: AND THE PEOPLE OF TEXAS
ARE PAYING THIS BILL TO PUT THEM
THROUGH THE PROCESS.
UNBELIEVABLE.
STEVE: WE CAN SHOW YOU THE
NUMBERS, BUT TO ACTUALLY SEE IT
WITH YOUR OWN TWO EYES AS YOU